is Caleb Williams the best NFL draft
prospect since Andrew Luck USC's Heisman
Trophy winning quarterback is the
expected number one pick of the 20124
draft and he's also chasing down Trevor
Lawrence as the top player since lux's
legendary 132.5 rating in 2011 Williams
threw for over 4,500 yards and 42
touchdowns last year thanks to his
rocket arm and Elite playmaking ability
he can make any throw you need and he
carves up defenses with his legs just
watch him turn absolutely nothing into
something against Notre Dame still don't
believe us then take it from David Shaw
who was Luck's offensive coordinator and
head coach at Stanford so I think
sometimes he takes maybe too many
chances but his improvisational skills
are to the level of Patrick Mahomes yeah
this guy's pretty good Lawrence lived up
to every bit of his Superstar Billing at
Clemson but he didn't create in college
like Williams can the Jaguars qb1 has
had a good run as the best since luck
but he might be passing the torch to
Williams next April